اذا اكبر استثمار في القدرات الدفاعيه
العسكريه في تاريخ استراليا هو مشروع شراء
غواصات تعمل بالدفع النووي الصفقات تقوم
على حصول استراليا على ثمانيه غواصات
نوويه تدخل الخدمه في سنه 2040 على ان
تكون استراليا قادره على تصنيع غواصاتها
النوويه بحلول سنه 2050 حسب توقعات
الحكومه الاستراليه فان قيمه هذه الصفقه
سوف تتراوح بين
268 الى 368 مليار دولار حتى سنه
وافقت هنا الولايات المتحده على بيع ثلاث
الى خمس غواصات نوويه الى استراليا من
طراز فيرجينيا التي تعد احدث الغواصات في
الوصول النوويه الامريكي غواصات فيرجينيا
مشاهدينا تبلغ قيمه القطعه الواحده منها
نحو ثلاث مليارات دولار وذلك يجعلها اغلى
الغواصات النوويه في العالم تتميز بالقدره
على القيام بمجموعه كبيره من المهام خصوصا
القدره العاليه على جمع المعلومات والتجسس
وخوض الحروب المضاده للغواصات تعد اول من
يستخدم تقنيه الاستشعار الضوئي عوض
المنظار التقليدي كونها مجهزه بكاميرات
عاليه الدقه واجهزه استشعار تكثيف الضوء
والاشعه تحت الحمراء وسلاح ليزر عالي
الطاقه بقدره تبلغ 500 كيلو وات اما عن
الغواصات النوويه التي ستصنع في استراليا
في عام 2040 فستكون على طراز الغواصات
النوويه
استوت وهي الجيل الاخير من الغواصات
النوويه البريطانيه المعززه ايضا بالتقنيه
النوويه الامريكيه يطلق عليها الزاهيه وهي
اكبر واقوى غواصات هجوميه في البحريه
الملكيه البريطانيه على الاطلاق تجمع بين
اجهزه الاستشعار العاليه الحساسيه
والاسلحه الرائده عالميه